thank you for taking the time to talk to
me i
absolutely adore this show and this
season is very fun
i i was curious though what was your
first reaction when you heard that this
would be
oregon trail for me that meant we were
going to be outside mostly
and doing a western so i didn't really
think about
you know what what it would entail you
know it was a pretty
uh challenging and dark period of
american history um
but i was just excited that that uh that
we were gonna
you know maybe get to ride a horse or
twirl a gun
and um all that yeah the original pitch
that
our writers dan and robert gave me for
this season was like
started in the darkest way possible that
an oregon trail thing could start
and we do eventually so that we we we
get to that point in the season
um but it was like immediately oh yeah
great we're going into some
like we're going to be able to have the
show that we have which is like light
and fun and sweet but also go to some
incredibly dark places
um and so yeah that was that was very
very exciting and we do
well i was curious i mean i know simon
stepped back from the day-to-day show
running
uh duties this season what was the
experience like uh you know this season
with them i know they were both writers
on the previous two seasons but didn't
anything feel different
this time around i mean not especially i
mean dan
and robert are so that they're so
brilliant and they
um and dan particularly was somebody i
had not met robert when he'd worked on
the second season but
uh i know that he did dan is somebody
that we've all worked like fairly
closely with for like three seasons now
so know really well and it felt like
even though
uh simon obviously wasn't there we
didn't lose any of the sort of the
shorthand that you have with the
writers because dan has also been here
for the whole time and knows us all
really well
yeah it felt like a natural handover
you know that that i think made us all
feel
good because especially last season dan
was on set a lot
and so it just seemed natural that that
he would be the one to continue
in that in that role do you guys have
much
input in kind of the creation and
development of your characters each
season and to kind of the journeys that
you'll be taking
you know each time out first season it
was you know for me it was just
presented
you know this is the character and i you
know embraced it
um a little yeah so a little bit more
in the second season but in the third
season the writers
you know uh dan and robert really wanted
to know you know what
uh what we wanted or if or if there's
anything that we wanted to try
and and i sort of just you know i was
happy to let them imagine
whatever they could imagine but the
thing
that i requested was just to have more
scenes with dan
um because that's the one thing that i
wish that i had done more of in
seasons one and two and they totally
embraced that
and you know we've you know we're like
side by side through
a lot of the show which um which i love
yeah and i had i had the same request
because if
the first two seasons we have like i
think we have maybe only one
scene in the first season where it's
just the two of us and then in
the second season we have that one
episode where we're together quite a lot
but that's that's basically
basically it um so yeah this season like
getting to work with steve moore just
the two of us was
fantastic um and yeah i think like steve
i really trust these
writers like i trust they're not gonna
you know we can
there's moments and conversations
throughout the series when you where you
calibrate the character slightly and you
think like oh i think is he like
you know is he getting too angry in this
scene for him to then get to where he
needs to be later you know you have
those kind of conversations but
in terms of the general arc of the
character and the person he is they that
was all you know all the writers and and
i was just very happy to jump into it
i've only been able to see one episode
but there's a really lovely father-son
dynamic between the two of you
i was wondering if that was fun or
interesting to explore because there's
kind of subtly maybe one in season one
just in terms of how your character
looks up to god and
you know wants to please him and then in
season two a little bit of you know a
guy searching for some kind of father
figure that would be
understanding this feels like it's
really compounding that and doubling
down on
yeah i think that there is i don't know
if we ever put it in those terms but
there is certainly
um because i think zeke is less of a
like zeke is slightly more capable than
either of the characters in the first
two seasons you know he is
he's more of a a grown person who
while he's not you know a man of the
world he's also not totally helpless or
a nervous wreck the whole time
um so i think they they in this series
they're more like
i think they've really come to respect
each other and zeke certainly you know
as
as an orphan is probably seeing some
sort of you know
father or or older brother figure or
something it better yeah
i didn't really think about that you
know um
but i could i could totally see it i
mean i just saw it more of
you know just two about two opposing set
of values
you know uh coming together and
um yeah maybe my character because he's
been around longer
you know you know assumes that he knows
more of the world and
and you know and this and this pastor
has a lot to learn
and i'm happy to teach him yeah steve i
know you
directed an episode uh prior did you
direct any of this new season yourself
yeah i got to direct two episodes uh in
this season
one where we're fording a river and
another where we're crossing a mountain
so both were
challenging in different ways but both
were uh so much fun
and um uh yeah it's uh
it was nice it was nice to be able to be
able to get to do two episodes yeah
i have to say you directed one of my
favorite episodes of 30 rock which was
the leap day episode
uh which i think is terrific dan is is
directing something that interests you
at all
you've worked with i mean some of the
best yeah i mean definitely i would i
would 100 want to direct
um hopefully in the next couple of years
i will i will get my ass in gear and
actually start doing something towards
that i have like
a script that i i think i want to try
and make
um so yeah gotta sort of stop talking
about that and actually do it but it's
it's yeah i think it's
it's on the point where it could be a
real thing soon hopefully
um but yeah it's it's i feel like it's
you know i think it looks like
i don't think i could do what steve does
which is also acting scenes
at the same time like that looks very
very like i feel like
part of the joy of directing me would be
like oh i don't have to worry about the
acting i don't want to i don't want to
do that
um but like i uh maybe one day if i had
more like certainly the first time i
direct would not want to also be
in it um but yeah it's uh it's
definitely something i want to do having
watched so many people
do it and and be really great at it i
hope hopefully some of that could be
passed on
well you know my final question for you
this year we're coming up on the 10th
anniversary of harry potter and the
deathly hallows part two
and i was just curious when you look
back on the experience of making and the
release of that film what uh what do you
kind of remember about that
i mean i remember like a lot obviously
there was um the release of that film
was insane
because i was doing uh i was doing a
musical on broadway
at the time and so they they they flew
me
back uh we they closed the theater for
like
a few uh nights and they flew me back
and had the last premiere
uh in you know in london and it was just
you know more people than i've ever seen
anywhere else in in my life or will ever
see again outside you know sporting
arenas
um so yeah it was it was crazy and cool
and
and i think the last film as well was
very uh was filled with a kind of
oh it's ending sort of feeling but even
that didn't become real until it
actually ended
um so yeah it was it was uh a
strange and lovely and yeah i've tons of
incredibly fond
fond memories of that of that last film
it's a remarkable film and a remarkable
franchise
um thank you both so much i'm such a
huge fan of this show i really hope you
guys just continue
uh doing this for a while because i just
love seeing you book together
i think you're so fantastic awesome
thank you so much i'm glad you love it
thank you
for sure have a good day